distant scream yeah there was a
tremendous concern you know Kashian came
on when we were at our darkest one of
the tart and Laura was coming in a
minute you know we we had an amazing
cast for a year
shopping us moving around and you know
couldn't find the money to do it and
yeah well that's true there were some
problems going on but it was it was
something people were very anxious about
you know me it's not it's not the
feel-good hit of the year so it was
something that was a challenge but we
stood by that and stood by the film's we
wanted to make and so Michael came in
and put his money where as
you know it was a year-long process
Zach's not going to tell you this but
one of the biggest things that allowed
us to get the cast that we ended up
getting was Zach sleeping his neck out
and being on the movie and actually that
the casting process was unbelievable it
was a moving puzzle and these guys use
the resources that they had and you know
one by one the thing came together in
this kind of the doorway but why
you know I mean the bottom line of that
for me is that actually the thing that
actors respond to is material I mean
good after everything here you know when
I read it was so unexpected I wanted to
get behind I think that other actors
that resonated for them and and Jacey's
affability is articulate articulate his
point of view and an instrument as the
first kind of future director put people
at ease in a way that I think disarmed
them you know these Jeremy Irons and
Kevin Spacey and Simon and you know
people that have been around and
understand what it means to make a movie
so I really I think all of the credit
goes back to Jersey or do all of the
everybody sign on because of the
screenplay
because of him so I have you know yeah
well it'd definitely be producing more
producing JCB's follow up teachers
emergent all which are we going to
pre-production both things for sure you
know I'm shooting star expected to do
right now and other things like that
going it's going amazingly well really a
great timing but yeah but my
relationship with Neil that's an
important most of my producing partners
is is you know paramount to my
experience as an artist and in this
business so I keep doing as much as I
can in that
thanks so much
haven't instrument especially slow
both of those things I mean we look for
stories that are complex that have
multi-dimensional characters but that
also have something to say you know I
don't think we take for granted our
audiences and their ability to engage in
a discourse of the dialogue that could
generate some illumination on things
that are really relevant socially and
politically you know obviously
economically but but but really it's
about it's about integrity and when we
met DC and when we read the screenplay
we knew that margin call and he had that
in spades so that was something that
that made the biggest difference in
terms of this project and the things
that we look for in the future yeah
thank you guys so much